dude you're bringing the energy today
you must be hype what was it like
getting that feedback from the crowd out
there it's a you know it's infectious we
got to sit there too like i hadn't seen
that sneak preview either so when they
played it me and al and q got down and
we looked up and we watched it they're
screaming we're screaming it was uh it
was it was intoxicating were your little
gel students could wear your costume too
to preview it
i thought about it i was like hmm
it would be nice we'll have to wait
until uh if if people want more then
maybe maybe if i get it out of smash or
if me and q get to do something we'll be
able to do that maybe just like you have
it in the van you put on the walk the
hall floor who knows right no i wouldn't
i if i could i would that's for sure so
how did your expectations of working
with dj match up to the experience
above and beyond i mean
you watch him you see him he's made his
life very accessible in a lot of ways
and so
it's incredible to see that and witness
that and then to be there and experience
him and what he does in person his
intelligence his compassion his
dedication to narrative his dedication
to the people around him and his family
and his friends and and and
the industries that he's been able to
conquer the way that he has i mean you
understand that you get it it makes a
lot of sense when you're with him in
person you get to spend more than a few
minutes with him which we all we're very
very fortunate too and you can't help
but but try to take in and soak in as
much as you possibly can yeah he's he's
become like this high watermark for kind
of how to operate in general what did
you take away from uh spending time with
him that you like apply to things now
man
he has time for
for for every idea and every person in
the room
um which is you know
something that i think we should all
take with us
um his dedication like i said earlier is
is is
so far up there in superior
um
and the the attention and energy that he
gives to to the things that he decides
to really lean into
uh he doesn't have everything or
anything at all you know he is fully in
but but he also is clearly very
contemplative about what it is that he
gives his energy and his time to
um
there's a lot you see there's so much
yeah
how is this team of heroes anti-heroes
perhaps
gonna leave their mark like what makes
them so unique
well you get to watch two very young
metahuman cyclone and adam smasher
become superheroes in this film
which is a little fresh right it's a
little new usually you're seeing a
superhero movie about superheroes that
are superheroes and they like and we get
to be very they're you know
in in their in their in their fully
formed phase but for us we still get to
figure that out so you see a beautiful
dynamic between hawkman and dr fate
teaching us what it means to be a
superhero um and how we fall in line i
just think and then you have dwayne
right black adam he's got a
different moral compass right the ethos
of his morality is uh is darker than
we're used to seeing
um
and we ask that question you know
what is right what is wrong in context
you have to ask with the context which
is a very
compelling question